in this video we're going to talk about
how to drink alcohol and still lose
weight is this possible well personal
personally I don't drink alcohol but
some of my patients do so they they
always want to know can I drink alcohol
Dr Burke it's a tricky thing it's
ultimately best if you avoid it but
let's say occasionally you want to
consume it what do you do to minimize
the damage um the other thing is if you
notice when you drink the more you drink
the more more you will have something
called a hangover okay and a hangover is
really your liver being pretty toxic and
that toxic waste product from the
alcohol is built up in the liver and
it's evading the brain and creating all
sorts of toxic feeling in your brain so
what you would want to do if you drank
some alcohol is right after drinking it
you would want to consume a kale shake
so you get home you drink the alcohol
drink the kale shake it cleans the liver
out faster so you wake up and you don't
have a hangover okay that's why B
vitamins are also good after you drink
to minimize the hangover because B
vitamins help detoxify the liver that's
interesting all right so again we're
really dealing with when we're deal with
alcohol we're dealing with the
traumatized liver so the real question
is how to drink
alcohol and not traumatize your liver so
much well we want to make up the damage
right after after you consume there's
other things you can do as well don't
spread out the alcohol for a whole week
get it over with in one short period of
time and then you're done because that
that spreading it out prolongs the
damage um if you have a choice between
beer wine or hard liquor I would go more
hard liquor because there's less sugar
and there's more carbohydrates in beer
wine um also be willing to not burn fat
for 48 to 72 hours because that's what
it's going to do to your liver if you
drink it's going to postpone and put you
out of fat burning so hey go go for it
drink the alcohol but just be aware of
what you're doing um of course if you're
doing champagne do the dry don't do the
sweet don't do the uh sweet Liquors
don't do Mad Dog 2020 please don't do
that I've done it in college that was a
very bad mistake and
um and the other thing
that I haven't tried this you might want
to try this and and email me and tell me
if it worked but uh if you had a
margarita a kale margarit so you take
all these tropical fruits you blend them
with the kale put the vodka in there put
the lemon in there put the coconut shake
it all up whatever and drink that I've
never tasted it I have no idea if it's
any good but that kale May inhibit some
of the damage to your liver so go ahead
and try it out and go ahead and make
comments on my
blog